alors que dira demain emmanuel macron à
guiseppe comptait acceptera-t-il
d'accueillir une partie des migrants
arrivés en italie comme le souhaite
rome on se pose la question après les
déclarations hors micro hors caméra du
chef de l'état devant 200 parlementaires
et membres de la république en marche
hier soir on ne peut pas ne pas regarder
ce sujet en face c'est ce qu'a déclaré
notamment emmanuel macron et vous pouvez
le lire sur l'écran la gauche n'a pas
voulu regarder ce problème pendant des
décennies les classes populaires ont
donc migrer vers l'extrême droite
on est comme les trois petits singes ça
les trois petits singes sont comme ça on
ne veut pas regarder en tout cas
regarder l'autre qui veut pas entendre
effectué
merci d'avoir fait cette précision
alors justement puisqu'on en est à
l'exégèse et je m'en charge jusqu'en fin
de soirée très bien le petit le 1er du
mois
en tout cas puisqu'on en est à l'exégèse
bas je vous propose d'écouter celles
qu'on faisait la ministre de la santé ce
matin à liège puissant le président
rappelait nous avions en train de
communautarisme et qu'il fallait le
regarder en face et qu'il fallait de
traité nous recevons mal les personnes
qui sont réellement en situation de
danger dans leur pays et par contre nous
ne sommes probablement pas assez ferme
avec l'immigration économique et donc le
président rappelait la règle il souhaite
qu'on soit meilleur avec ce qui fut leur
pays pour de bonnes raisons et la
fermeté vis-à-vis de l'immigration
purement économique alors phil meier il
est courageux
lucide le président il est à la fois
habile parce que enfin dire nous ne
pouvons pas éviter le problème
ça veut dire aussi aux autres vous ne
pouvez pas éviter non plus et donc sur
ce sujet retrouvons-nous analyse
contre-analyses projet contre projet
mais sortons de des grandes déclarations
pleines de bonne volonté qui sont
nécessaires sans doute a forgé l'âme des
uns et des autres mais qui sur le
terrain n'aboutisse absolument à rien
tout le monde connaît des exemples de
gens qui
tout en ayant officiellement un discours
extrêmement bienveillant à l'égard de
telle ou telle catégorie d'immigrés
s'empresse de mettre leurs enfants dans
des lycées privés pour qu'ils ne
fréquentent pas les enfants de cela ou
bien de dézoner comme on dit élégamment
l'éducation nationale de dézoner leurs
enfants pour qu'ils ne soient pas
obligés de supporter certaine
promiscuité qui sur le papier sont
considérés comme le signe de la plus
grande civilisation et respect des
droits de l'homme et qui dans la réalité
sont contournées ni plus ni moins donc
moi ce que j'aime dans cette situation
créée par emmanuel macron c'est que
maintenant il va falloir causés et il va
falloir que chacun dise sa position
disent d'abord son analyse de la
situation
sk communautarisme sk pas
communautariste et comment est-ce qu'il
faut répondre à ces questions de
l'immigration économique comme ce qu'il
faut répondre à ces questions d'asile
politique et c'est là maintenant la
manière dont ils créent me semble-t-il
un choc devrait obliger à faire autre
chose qu'à aligner des bons sentiments
pericos et moi si j'en crois les dernier
numéro de marianne vous devez plutôt
content de ces déclarations alors pour
moins que ça pour dire - cha on est
immédiatement traité de souverainisme de
xénophobe de nationalisme alors corse et
dans la bouche des manuels macron on
peut considérer à l'extrême gauche c'est
d'ailleurs laurent joffrin trouvé ça
d'une violence oui il ne fait que dire
mais sauf que j'écoutais bruno
retailleau ce matin je ne partage pas
forcément ses opinions peser sur nos
vins de france inter on est en campagne
électorale on sort ça du chapeau jusqu'à
présent c'était tabou fallait pas en
parler c'était pas vrai c'était le
discours du rassemblement national c'est
un discours lepéniste écoles présentes à
un public s'en emparent pour des raisons
qui visiblement vote électoral parce
qu'il faut on se doute qu'à la fin son
sceptre de son quinquennat il fera un
petit peu à gauche pour récupérer les
voix de gauche qui sont cocufié par tous
les mensonges et tous tes promesses non
tenues et la maintenant dans un type
comme il ya un problème avec
l'immigration en europe on dans un petit
bois on est en permanence dans le doigt
mouillé à savoir d'où vient le vent que
faut-il dire à quel moment
selon les sondages d'opinion ce n'est
pas comme ça qu'on gouverne la
république et je vous dis qu'il n'est
pas crédit
ce discours là il a fait le contraire de
ce qu'il disait toute sa vie pourquoi
maintenant il tiendrait parole alors
vous me donner le mot justement je
voulais poser la question de vous donner
le bon est ce que c'était la question je
vais vous poser les pièces qu'il est
crédible justement ça on verra
c'est pas parce qu'on dit les choses
qu'on l'ait fait mais c'est pape
je pense que si on ne le dit pas on est
sûr de ça les fait donc c'est déjà bien
de les dire oui je me suis va j'ai
protesté râler pendant des mois et des
mois parce que cet angle là d'une
réalité que nous constatons que les
français constatent n'étaient pas prises
en compte
je vais pas aujourd'hui faire la fine
bouche il le prend en compte on verra
bien s'il agit ce sens il agit pas ici
prendre un truc dans la figure s'il
n'agit pas cela sera exactement comme
sarkozy j'agite je mets le doigt sur une
réalité douloureuse et je fais rien pour
la résoudre
donc je me prends tout dans la figure
donc il faut moi je crois qu'il faudra
qu'ils agissent on verra bien mais
n'empêche que rien que le fait il vient
de loin quand même parce que ceux qui
dit aujourd'hui ce n'est pas non plus
enfin dire qu'il ya trop d'immigration
qu'elle ait un contrôle et que les
classes populaires en soufre que les
bourgeois n'en souffrent pas un lapin en
tout cas bon on n'a pas attendu mais
n'empêche que la l'extérieur extrêmement
atteints depuis longtemps la droite une
pilotant manuel valls le disait à
l'époque comme une valse le disait mâcon
se moucher un peu le nez ça se fait donc
c'est un vrai changement me semble-t-il
de pied sémantique idéologique en
paroles eux c'est déjà ça je ne me
contenterai pas mais n'empêche que rien
que ça ça me paraît déjà prendre en
compte la réalité c'est le premier pas
maintenant on va falloir faire les
autres et on le verra assez vite puisque
va y avoir de la réunion il
il avait quand même posé quelques jalons
après les jets les jours dit commencer à
dire il ya un problème d'immigration
elle alors que s'agissait pas de façon
absolument émotions du groupement
familial pour les migrants et donc ils
en parlent
et puis dit on va faire un grand débat
sur l'immigration et je sais que ça
plaît pas à certains dans mon camp on va
le faire à l'assemblée la bientôt au
pied au sénat on verra bien si ce débat
si on parle on parle et on ne fait rien
il se prendra tout dans la figure si à
partir de ce qui dit prend des mesures
l'annoncé d'une décision là bravo
frédéric avant d'avoir votre analyse
puisque on en parlait justement jouer
vous faire écouter
justement la réaction de
bruno retailleau ce matin il semble
fermer fait semble en réalité je vais
vous donner un exemple pour moi fera pas
puisque nous avons il ya un an voter un
texte en tout cas au sénat nous ne
l'avons pas voter nous l'avons critique
et qui était portée par gérard collomb
asile immigration
ça fait exactement un an que cette loi a
été promulguée et alors voilà le
président de la république qui se dit
parce que sans doute que pour les
sondages pour ce n'est lectorat il ya
peut-être d'autres clins d'oeil à la
droite ou à la droite de la droite à
faire et il fait cette sortie là alors
est ce qu'il ya des clins d'oeil à
droite la droite de la droite à faire
s'il ya des réserves
oui c'est vrai que sur ces sujets
régaliens c'est une manière puisque
jamais de conserver cet électorat de
droite c'est 25% des lectorats fillon
qui ont choisi la réplique en marge qui
sont attachés à l'ordre et à la sécurité
la question c'est vrai ça a été dit
qu'elle aimait le maquereau avons-nous
face à nous celui de 2015 qui soutient
fortement au sein du gouvernement de
manuel valls
l'appel aux migrants d'angela merkel ou
celui du grand débat parce qu'il avait
commencé à poser ses jalons avec un
discours aussi ferme au moment du grand
débat c'est est une des questions que
les gens c'était une des questions qui
étaient posées aux français il faut dire
franchement
force est de constater que des personnes
qui ont participé au grand débat ne se
sont pas emparés dans une enquête de
l'ifop d'il ya quinze jours sur les
principales préoccupations des français
la lutte contre l'immigration
clandestine est relégué derrière le
diptyque santé environnement et le
diptyque pouvoir d'achat emploi mais il
est premier voire majeur au
rassemblement national et dans l'électro
à droite et puis c'est vrai que
l'opinion publique à gauche comme à
droite on acte un vrai durcissement
je vais dire en enchères alexis un vrai
durcissement des français sur
l'immigration tirent les salaires vers
le bas ce sont des phrases qu'on a
proposé aux français dans une enquête
ifop jdd pourrait d'ici que
l'immigration coûte plus qu'elle ne
rapporte un la fameuse antienne de
bernard stasi trois quarts des français
n'y croient plus mais deux choses d'une
part c'est d'une question qui réactive
formidablement le clivage gauche droite
même si la date même si la gauche est
beaucoup plus dur que par le passé et
puis c'est une question où les français
sont malgré tout malgré eux
durcissement rocardien à la phrase est
ce que c'est le devoir de notre pays
d'accueillir des migrants qui fut la
guerre et la misère
nous avons 61 % des français qui
déclarent oui y compris une part non
négligeable d'électeurs des républicains
oui mais je crois qu'il s'adresse mais
vous disais bien au delà de la droite
c'est vrai aux catégories populaires
quand on regarde vous parlez d
excellents sondage de l'ifop n'est pas
tout il ya sur ma chips haussière qui
est excellent en israël
excellent publiée par le monde où on
voit que 64% des français disent on ne
se sent plus chez nous 63% disent il ya
trop d'immigrés 66 % disent ils font pas
d'efforts pour s'intégrer
donc c'est pas que la droite ces
affaires là beaucoup plus loin et dire
si ce moment donc macron bien sûr il ya
une calcul droite gauche mais ainsi
calcul de dire je ne peux pas laisser
les catégories populaires au fonds
national sinon il se passera chez nous
ce qui se passe en italie ce qui se
passe en lever que le brésil en
angleterre et rails ce qui se passe aux
etats unis ce qui se passe chez urban ce
qui se passerait dans tous les pays
occidentaux
c'est que si je les pays si les partis
traditionnels ne prennent pas en compte
semble de réalité d'autres partis pas
les prennent à leur place philippe
justement sur ce sur ce sondage les
chiffres sont quand même sont quand même
impressionnant quand on va non seulement
des 66 % qui estiment que les immigrés
ne font pas d'efforts pour s'intégrer et
effectivement qu'on rajoute les 64 % qui
estiment qu'on ne se sent plus chez soi
comme un oui je peux pas dire que je ne
crois pas aux sondages veut pas dire ça
en présence du son du grand du grand
sondeur mais je crois pas qu'on puisse
leur faire dire tellement de choses il
ya à travers ça biya qu'est ce qui a en
fait c'est bien ce que j'aimerais savoir
sk vraiment l'idée qu'on se sent plus
chez soi ou wes cas une façon de
traduire la la conviction
l'expérience qu'on a quand on perd le
contrôle de sa propre existence
moi je suis frappé de voir ça je suis
pour pour partie fin je suis assez
souvent dans l'aveyron à la frontière du
cantal dans des endroits où il ya eu des
gilet jaune plus dans le cantal
d'ailleurs que dans l'aveyron mais il ya
cette exaspération alors qu'ils qui la
paye évidemment là
à ladoux dont je parle on peut pas dire
que les immigrés soient extrêmement
nombreuses
mais c'est quand même un sujet constant
de conversation de bistrot ou de
manifestations dans la chasse tout ce
que vous voudrez puisque elle rouvre
maintenant qui est que je prends un
exemple arrêter d'utiliser votre voiture
on a transporté la perception d'abord à
20 km et maintenant à 45 kilomètres des
20 km et comment on fait mais dans ce
genre de situation on a l'impression
qu'on brasse de l'air
il faut s'en prendre à quelque chose
mais est ce qu'on s'en prendrait lui
dire c'est que les immigrés sont ok me
sers de ce mal être le bouc émissaire je
pense le bouc émissaire verbal je dirais
le bouc émissaire et et les bouquets
boucs émissaires on y aurait vraiment
des incidents je veux répondre
ponctuellement monsieur meyer qui
fréquentent des territoires que je
fréquente aussi il y a aujourd'hui du
voile et quelquefois du voile intégral
dans des petites communes du lot du tarn
ou de l'aveyron le massif central
non je vais aussi dans ce territoire je
vois les gens qui sont plus posés plus
pu mesurer qu'il pourrait y avoir dans
des zones d'agglomération la
confrontation épisode nous avons quand
même des territoires perdus de la
république s'est avéré c'est plus c'est
plus une source de débats ces
scientifiques c'est démontrer et n'était
pas dans le lot
alors il ya des territoires que la
publicité en l'avenir on prend non on
dit pour l'instant il voit ce qui se
passe dans les médias il ya des réseaux
sociaux il ya des restrictions tout à
fait informelle sont tout à fait
conscients on s'étonnait des populations
alsacienne il ya 20 ans qui commencent à
voter front national alors qu'ils
n'avaient pas un émigré il savait très
bien quels sont les enjeux il ne voulait
pas que ça leur arrive les gens du
massif central que je vais voir qui me
disent il me dit justement parce que
nous ne sommes pas confrontés à cette
situation nous ne voulons pas d'être
confrontés à cette situation on veut
prévenir on ne veut pas guérir parce
qu'on ne peut pas guérir on veut
prévenir
qu'est ce qu'on fait mais il ya une
vraie conscience aujourd'hui qui a des
territoires perdus de la république et
il ya des des instants il ya des moments
dans france où effectivement on n'est
plus dans la france que nous conte
vont entendre français le débat est
ouvert qu'est ce que la france mais
l'angoissé réel
elle ne fait que monter 66% 64% je pense
en vérité que c'est plus que ça il ya
des gens qui font attention
alors justement frédéric est ce que
c'est une tendance que vous observez
dans vos enquêtes et on rappelle que
c'est la question se compose également
sur le figaro.fr pensez vous qu emmanuel
macron peut faire preuve de fermeté sur
l'immigration la question les français
sont assez perplexe et belle macron
échappe complètement à une critique
majeure chez françois hollande et qui a
également à fleuret chez nicolas sarkozy
s'était in action on a le sentiment
qu'il transforme le pays parfois pas à
son
à son avantage sur la question
migratoire et la loi il ya un an où
l'opinion a plutôt bien suivi parce que
la loi était perçu comme un point
d'équilibré entre une gauche laxiste
dans l'imaginaire des français et une
droite qui courait derrière le
rassemblement national par rapport à ce
que disait philippe meyer oui les
sondages sont parfois insuffisants c'est
à dire que les français sont assez je
dirais pas contradictoire mais plastique
et à multi facettes sur la question
migratoire il la lit quand même
fortement y compris dans ses territoires
du lot du cantal à la question
économique et un pessimisme de
projection qui est mes enfants vivront
moins bien que moi et il ya aussi cette
dimension qui rejette moins de
l'immigration que de l'insécurité
culturel c'est ce mixte l'un qui fait
que cette question qui n'est je le
répète jamais la première préoccupation
des français pourquoi il nous mentirait
sur cette question alors qui nous dirait
peut-être la vérité sur fait
l'environnement elle est quand même
assez connecter à d'autres questions
économiques pouvoir d'achat les généraux
ne sont pas descendus dans la rue pour
la question migratoire
mais sur la question du pouvoir d'achat
savait pas dire que cette question
n'existe pas mais il faut pas la prendre
de manière je dirais autarcique un nom
mais sans doute le fait puisque chacun
pu remarquer que parmi les jaunes y
avait finalement très peu d'immigrés de
c'était c'est un mouvement de petits
blancs ça veut aussi dire quelque chose
c'est la moyenne ou la classe populaire
de la classe populaire de souche blanc
d'oeuf et cela en fait on dit à 2 france
3 france il ya la france d'en haut la
france mondialisée la france des élites
la france de l'écologie est tous à la
france dé gilet jaune populaire classes
moyennes en voie de paupérisation et
puis la france détenant pis la france
des banlieues et étrangère et donc
arsenault 6ème en mai
mieux quand elle apprend sur la rue rose
était sur les ronds points mais alors là
franchement j'ai vu ça on enfile et n
est pas tous files étaient saisis sont
parfois encore si son parti qui était
parfaitement intégrée à six banques
étaient parfaitement intégrés rencontre
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est qu'ils
aient un sentiment global qui fait
système où il ya de la préoccupation
économique le sentiment que la
mondialisation est quelque chose
d'absolument incontrôlée qui devra de
perte de contrôle de fait que les
enfants vivront moins bien que les laits
tout sera plus difficile demain il y à
l'immigration il ya la perte des repères
culturels fatous il ya tout un ensemble
de choses où les gens subissent unis
sont dans une pièce de lessiveuse mais
un d'éléments un des éléments qui
ressort de tout ça peut-être les plus
visibles et les plus en tout cas
repérable c'est la question de
l'immigration qui disent ça change ce
monde qui est en train de se dessiner
n'est plus mon monde n'est plus celui
dans lequel j'ai grandi et n'est plus au
fond celui qui sera accueillant pour mes
enfants c'est ça l'idée alors on va
conclure avec les internautes cij qui
nous dit le président fait ça pour faire
baisser un peu le vote et rennes mais ce
n'est que de la com breugnot tout le
monde peut faire preuve de fermeté sur
l'immigration au moins en dix courses le
potentiel électoral et la babineau je
pense que macron veut envoyer le signal
que le gouvernement et décomplexée sur
ce sujet ce n'est pas le monopole du r'n
et geneviève s'interroge pourquoi avoir
attendu si longtemps pour ouvrir les
yeux on continuera d'en débattre et je
vous appelle vous le voyez la question
qu'on vous pose sur lefigaro.fr pensez
vous qu emmanuel macron peut faire
preuve de fermeté sur l'immigration vous
pouvez continuer à y répondre
que vous habitiez en france ou bien dans
le massif central ou bien dans la
diagonale dans la diana liévin 2 2 tab
plus tard au cantal de montauban à
aurillac en passant bien sûr par rodez
et millau et sans oublier cahors